حسنًا ،
سنأتي الآن إلى مستعمرة العقوبات حيث
سيقضي أليكسي نافالني
العامين ونصف العام المقبلين ، إنها في الواقع
بضع ساعات فقط
من موسكو ، لذا سيكون من الأسهل
على أصدقائه وعائلته
وزملائه  تعال وقم بزيارته هنا ،
لكن هذا لا يعني أن
زعيم المعارضة الروسية يحصل على رحلة سهلة
لأن
هذه المستعمرة العقابية المعينة في
منطقة فلاديمير
هي واحدة من أشهر المستعمرات الروسية المخبأة
خلف السياج المموج
والأسلاك الشائكة الصدئة المستعمرة رقم 2
تبدو كئيبة
مكان غير مرحب به لا يمكنك رؤيته كثيرًا
من الخارج ،
لكن ناقد بوتين نافالني حلق رأسه
قد بث بالفعل انطباعاته
على إنستغرام لم يكن لدي أي فكرة أنه من
الممكن ترتيب
معسكر اعتقال حقيقي قريب جدًا من
موسكو الذي نشره
والفريق وراء البحرية الذي هو
بالفعل  نجا من التسمم بغاز الأعصاب
قبل أن يوضع خلف القضبان
وقد بث أيضًا صور الطائرات بدون طيار هذه
من أعلى
والتي تُظهر الثكنات الكئيبة حيث
سجن المستعمرة العقابية
يأكلون العمل وينامون من 50 إلى 60 شخصًا
محشورين في مسكن واحد ، ويقولون أن السجناء السابقين
ليسوا مثاليين أثناء انتشار الوباء ، فهذه
كنيسة
، وهذا هو المكان الذي كنت فيه ، هذا هو المكان
الذي مكثت فيه باستمرار ،
ويقول إنه لن ينسى محنته من
الداخل.  تم سجنه هنا مرتين
أخبرني بعد أن تم اعتقاله في
احتجاجات مناهضة للكرملين استمرت قرابة
عام
ما وصفه بأنه تعذيب نفسي
، لن يكون من السهل على حد قوله بالنسبة لأليكسي
نيفالني
إنهم يمنعونك من التحدث مع
مدانين آخرين أخبرني أنك  على قدميك
طوال اليوم من 6 صباحًا إلى 10
مساءً ولم يُسمح لك مطلقًا بالجلوس ، لا يمكنك
حتى قراءة أو كتابة الرسائل التي يقولها
لأسابيع متتالية ، وإذا انتهكت أي
قاعدة صغيرة ،
فسوف تتعرض للإهانة والإهانة
حتى أبعد من ذلك كما يقول
الروسية  تصر سلطات السجن على أن
نيفالني سيعامل مثل
أي سجين آخر ولن يتم تمييزه ،
لكن
التدقيق هنا غير مرحب به ، فهذه هي
البوابة الأمامية لمستعمرة السجن حيث
تم اعتقال أليكسا نافالني ،
يمكنك رؤيته  كل هؤلاء الحراس ينتظروننا ،
أحد الرجال يهز رأسه
هناك بالكلب الجميل ،
هل من الممكن التسجيل في هذه
المنطقة
للتسجيلات
لأنه
إقليم السجن الذي قالوا إنه لا يمكننا
حتى التسجيل فيه  كونوا هنا الروس معروفون
بالسرية
بشأن سجونهم لأنهم يعرفون
أن الظروف في
الداخل سيئة ليس فقط في هذا السجن ولكن في
السجون في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، يُظهر
هذا الفيديو المزعج الذي نشرته إحدى
الصحف الروسية
تعرض السجناء للضرب المبرح من قبل
الحراس
في مستعمرة عقابية في ياروسلاف  المنطقة
المجاورة لمكان احتجاز البحرية
، أدانت المحكمة الروسية العديد
من الأشخاص بالتورط
في ما أصبح فضيحة سجن وطني ،
ومن المعروف بين
السجناء أن
هذه الأنواع من الضرب منتشرة في
أغلب الأحيان ، حيث يقومون بفك ساق الكرسي
وضرب الناس على كعوبهم
أخبرني السجين السابق ، لكن بعد
فضيحة تسممه
، من المحتمل أن يرغبوا في الحفاظ على
صحة البحرية.  هدف وريث هو
تقييد اتصالاته
وحرمانه من صوته ، فهذا
ممنوع
وإخفاء ناقد الكرملين الأكثر شهرة في روسيا
عن الأنظار تمامًا ، شكرًا
لك
ماثيو فرصة سي إن إن فلاديمير روسيا